while join me now to discuss this is to
found the world's most influential
Progressive online Channel The Young
Turks and Democratic presidential
hopeful and that's Jen you go Jen great
to have you on the program thank you
very much indeed for joining me I'll be
following your tweets with interest uh
this week you've been getting
increasingly angry I think it'd be fair
to say he said I'm now enormously
frustrated by us and Israeli
government's barbaric acts in Gaza I
will not be shy in sharing that opinion
on Piers Morgan show today um why are
you so frustrated
yeah well honestly I I didn't expect the
framing that you put on this segment and
it's uh framing like that that's
disgusting so I don't see what this has
anything to do with anti-Semitism I I
formed Young Turks in tyt with two
Jewish friends who are some of my
friends growing up we've known each
other and been Brothers for over 40
years now so I think what Hamas did is
disgusting I cry uh for those Israeli
innocent Civ Ians uh but do I see you
guys crying for Palestinians I mean
Chris chrisy was just on here treating
it like it's no big deal because what
Palestinian lives don't matter I think
the real bigotry here is saying that
Palestinians we can kill three times as
many of them already and this is the
appetizer Netanyahu and his barbaric
government have not even started the
entree of murder and death in mayem
they're about to do and that's somehow
okay killing three times as many
Palestinian civil I let alone the
occupation which is bigotry by
definition we say that everyone in the
world can uh defend themselves can have
their own State can have sovereignty
except the Palestinians and the
reasoning behind that is the
Palestinians are what are they're what
the idea is that they are savages and
that Muslims are too violent and cannot
control themselves so they must be
occupied for 56 brutal disgusting years
so I've had enough of the big bigotry
against Muslims and Palestinians and I
need you to speak out against that
instead of covering every outrageous
atrocious action of the right-wing
government of Israel and go oh it's
anti-Semitism no when and there is
global anti-Semitism there's
anti-Semitism here in this country two
synagogues were shot up Pittsburgh and
in Southern California we fight against
that all the time but then when whenever
Israel is criticized you people go oh no
it's anti-Semitism no there's real
anti-Semitism instead of that instead of
attacking that all you guys ever do is
hide behind the veil of anti-Semitism do
you know why Palestinians might not like
Israelis because they've been oppressed
56 straight years I I hear you I hear
you and let me respond uh a I'm not you
guys I don't think I fit into any neat
fit on this issue at all um B I've
actually covered the story I think more
Fair than most people I've had many pro
Palestinian voices I've given a huge
platform for they've been getting
enormous audiences from Bassam YF to
others and I've done that quite
deliberately because I think these
voices I think these voices are
important to be heard including yours U
I certainly wasn't accusing you by the
way or your organization of
anti-Semitism I just think I have found
it as somebody who's always identified
as liberal myself I found it very
dispiriting to see people who call
themselves liberals who've whose instant
respon it seemed to me to one of the
worst Terror attacks we've ever seen was
to immediately side with the place where
these attacks have been launch from now
I don't tar all Palestinians with the
brush of being Hamas at all uh and in
fact the sooner Hamas are out of there
the better for the Palestinian people
and the world um but I just think the
only human response you can have is as
you did by the way to your credit is it
was disgusting what happened on October
the 7th now the question then becomes
what is a proportionate response by isra
Isel uh not just of the terror attacks
of October the 7th but obviously there
is now a huge ongoing escalation in what
has been as you rightly say a
56-year uh War effectively in varying
degrees over that period and that's
where I think I I I'm struggling to see
how a ground Invasion by Israel with all
that that would entail particularly Mass
deaths of Palestinian civilians how that
is going to do anything for any piece of
resolution to this I think it will have
the opposite
effect yes so let's say you one at a
time first of all as you rightly point
out on Young Turks uh we covered uh the
atrocious actions of Hamas right from
the get-go and we condemned it as fully
as anyone can possibly condemn it
because not only are they killing those
poor innocent Israelis that didn't do
anything those little babies and the
grandmothers it's disgusting what they
did but on top of that they've they're
ruining the Palestinian cause they've
burned the moral High Ground to Cinders
and then on top of that they smear all
people of Muslim background like myself
and and and then it leashes this
unleashes this bigotry of anti-muslim
bigotry throughout the world that I'm
sick of so screw Hamas and their
barbarism okay now in terms of a proper
reaction yes you need to get those
hostages out so now let's look at what
it I'm going to suggest what to actually
do I'm going to be constructive but
first let's look at the unconstructive
solution that Israel had dropping bombs
on residential buildings 50 ambulance
ambulances have been hit 10 out of 25
hospitals don't operate anymore the
incubators are about to run out of
energy there's 45 babies that might die
today the parents I just read on CNN are
writing the names of the kids on their
calves on their legs so that if they are
killed in a bombing and they're
mutilated
they could find their bodies imagine
writing the name of your child on their
legs so that you could find them in the
rubble after Israel or any government
drops a bomb on them and I need the West
to understand something bombs kill
people and do you know how they kill
people they incinerate them alive or
their heads explode so what happened in
Israel was a was a disaster and
disgusting but you have to be equally
honest and it and equally outraged at
the immorality of incinerating babies
and grandmothers and aunts and uncles
which is what we're doing right now
America cannot keep sending aid for
death and destruction enough of the
occupation end it today end it today
it's monstrous okay I'm gonna let me
solution let me a I completely
understand your passion and your anger I
completely get
this I like you want to see some
resolution at the end of this this
horror that we're
witnessing how do you get rid of Hamas
if you don't do it the way Israel are
currently doing it how do you actually
eradicate what has become a nihilistic
Isis style terror group who've quite
deliberately in my estimation committed
an outrage of such appalling scale that
they knew that this would go Israel into
this kind of response so why they did
that what is motivating it who might be
putting them up to it who's helped them
prepare for this these are all questions
we don't know the answers to yet but it
seems to me that Israel could if it's
not careful be being lured into a
massive trap here and I I hope that is
not the case but I'm curious how do you
get rid of Hamas if you don't do it the
way Israel is currently doing it albeit
with horrific collateral damage in in in
the in the in the face of thousands of
innocent Palestinians being caught up in
the
buming yeah so let me give you
short-term answer long-term answer and a
lot of people are not going to like
these but these are realistic ways that
you minimize minimize civilian
casualties you do what America did with
the Osama Bin Laden raate we didn't go
drop a nuke on Pakistan we didn't go
destroy 6,000 residential buildings in
the middle of Pakistan we sent in
Special Forces is it more dangerous to
the special forces of course that's the
point of Special Forces try to find the
hostages does it look like Israel is
trying to find the hostages if I have a
family member that's hostage I'm
disgusted what by what nyaho is doing
now how do you know they're not in the
buildings you're dropping bombs on how
do you know they're not in the tunnels
you're dropping bombs on how do you know
they're not in the hospitals you're
dropping bombs on so this if you want
the hostages rescued every rational
human being can agree this is not the
way to do it this is the way to do death
and Destruction for the sake of death
and destruction it's Collective
punishment it's genocide against
Palestinians and the world has to speak
out so my way is not pleasant either it
involves a lot of folks dying on on both
sides I understand that those are super
hard choices but go find Hamas go find
the hostages go rescue them in send them
wanting in
indiscriminately killing after killing
and let's be honest when you drop a bomb
and and a and a kid's head explodes and
a grandmother is incinerated that is
Terrorism killing three times as many C
civilians as
Hamas is
Terrorism and it is the same if it is
done by a government sending as many
special forces you got we should send
look send in whatever you got to
actually do the job at hand instead of
what you're what Netanyahu is doing
which is to to kill these people to what
send a message and think about how
unrealistic that is and think about why
his chance his method has a 0% chance of
working how are the Palestinians
supposed to rise up against Hamas how
would they prove they're against Hamas
Hamas ended all elections Hamas ended
democracy so how are the Palestinians
supposed to cry Uncle they're already
crying uncle but it's never enough for
the bloodthirsty Netanyahu no more death
of Palestinians more babies killed
that's what his answer is and it's this
and the United States of America I'm
running for president here there's no
way in the world I would allow this
sending $105 billion dollar that's and
it doesn't even go to Israel Ukraine or
Taiwan it those are the defense
contractors that are get that bribe
these greedy American politicians and
then get most of that money and so the
longterm answer is 1967 borders and the
biggest walls you've ever seen in your
entire life and no one's allowed to
cross the either side but the
Palestinians get their state it is
unconscionable for them not to get their
state and if you're a moral person you
of course you believe that the
Palestinians are not the only people in
the world that cannot govern themselves
if you say that you are being by
definition bigoted and a racist we have
to have two-state solution immediately
immediately if 56 years of occupation
and brutalizing these people is not
enough is 57 years going to be enough is
156 years going to be enough I'm asking
Israel not out of hate out of love so
many of my friends that I grew up with
are Jewish this is not good for them
this is not good for anybody please look
into your hearts look and be the moral
people that I know you can be I've been
to Passover dinners where you pray for
your oppressors now I breaks my heart
but I got to tell you you got to pray
for those you are oppressing and to say
that you are not oppressing the
Palestinians after brutalizing them for
56 long years you're kidding yourself
and as a friend and an ally I'm trying
to get you to wake up and snap out of
this trans you cannot keep doing this it
is ruining your moral
fiber Jen Yuga thank you very much
indeed for joining me I greatly
appreciate I'm sorry it was your first
appearance on this program under these
circumstances but I won't be your last I
think you're an important voice in this
and I do appreciate you coming on the
show thank you very much thank
you